next up I'd like to talk about the match
this is the strongest Mac lineup we ever
have had we continue to innovate we've
continued to lead the industry and more
importantly we continue to provide the
very best experience for our customers
and this is the reason that for every
year for the last decade the Mac has
outgrown the industry and if you look at
notebooks the numbers are even more
telling last year the industry shrank
and the Mac grew over 20 percent this is
phenomenal and if when you're out in the
wild you will see Mac's everywhere now
they're in schools they're in businesses
they're in coffee shops in airports and
hopefully they're in your living room
but the definition of portability has
changed in the last several years led by
iPhone and iPad so we challenged
ourselves to take everything that we had
learned in designing iPhone and iPad and
do something incredibly ambitious and
bold we challenged ourselves to reinvent
the notebook and we did it
and here it is
you gotta know I'm feeling you gotta
know
it's gotta be
and here it is
it is unbelievable can you even see it I
can't even feel it there it goes
I'd like I'd like to invite Phil
Schiller up to tell you all about it
bill
good morning everyone I'm so excited to
tell you all about this incredible new
MacBook is the most extreme and
efficient notebook we have ever created
and it took reinventing every technology
in it to deliver something this amazing
and it absolutely looks gorgeous from
every angle
the new MacBook weighs just 2 pounds
this is the lightest Mac we have ever
made and even its thickest point it's
just thirteen point one millimeters thin
that's the thinnest Mac we have ever
made as well in fact the previous
thinnest Mac here it is the 11 inch
MacBook Air as you can see the new
MacBook is 24% thinner that is a huge
difference and as you look around at
every angle you see well this is an
all-metal
enclosure the team has integrated the
antennas right into the enclosure it's
the first time we've been able to do it
that way and when you open it up you're
struck by one of its most dominant
features that keyboard there's a
full-size keyboard it goes all the way
to the edge that actually defines the
size of the notebook that keyboard and
it's not just any keyboard it is an
all-new keyboard as you move to a
thinner design it took entirely new kind
of invention to make it a beautiful
keyboard so the team studied how current
keyboard technology works here's a
slow-motion video of a customer typing
on a standard keyboard and as you see as
the keys get pressed they're a bit
wobbly in fact if you press them on the
side they start to bottom out that's
because they're based on a mechanism
called a scissor mechanism and there's a
time when that was great but now there's
something new our team invented a
butterfly mechanism this butterfly
mechanism is built of a single assembly
and it's supported by
stainless-steel dome switch and that all
adds up to a key that is much more
precise inaccurate in fact it's four
times more stable than that scissor
mechanism it is 40 percent thinner
allowing us to make a thinner keyboard
and we also made the key cap larger
making it even easier to strike and get
a beautiful typing experience that's the
first new feature on the new MacBook and
all-new full-size keyboard well the
perfect size display to match to that
full-size keyboard is a twelve inch
display with full edge to edge cover
glass and to be beautiful of course it's
a Retina display a Retina display with
23:04 by 1440 pixels if you do the math
that's just over three point three
million pixels it is a beautiful display
the panel is just point eight eight
millimeters thin this is the thinnest
display we've ever built into a Mac and
those pixels have a larger aperture for
life what's that about
well an individual pixel is made up of
red green and blue sub pixels the team
has been able to miniaturize electronics
and move them out of the way so more
light comes through each pixel so the
same level brightness it actually
consumes thirty percent less energy such
our finished display our most
energy-efficient display it truly is the
best display we've ever built onto a map
next up the trackpad this is an
incredible feat of Engineering a
traditional trackpad is hinged at the
top and as you click on it it moves like
a diving board so the top end is stiffer
in the bottom end is softer well not
with this trackpad we call it the force
touch trackpad there's a glass
multi-touch surface but built underneath
it of four four sensors and for the
first time in a trackpad our taptic
engine that you've heard about with
watch is built into here as well to
provide feedback of your clicking this
is an incredibly thin
capable trackpad and for the first time
you can cook anywhere and get the exact
same feel over the entire surface it's
not hinged like a diving board in that
field because it's management software
you can adjust it if you want to have a
stiffer or softer feel to your trackpad
but what it can do is so much more than
that
those four sensors sense a range of
pressure from your lightest click to a
deeper press we've created a new gesture
for those deeper presses we call them a
force click so how does that work
well in OS 10 when you force click for
example in a word in a browser you
automatically get a Wikipedia lookup of
that if you're an email and you see an
address you force click on it and you
automatically get a map that pops up
with a location maybe someone has
invited you and sent you a date and time
you force click on that and it
automatically creates a calendar entry
you can even force click on a file in
the finder and automatically get a
preview of the contents of that file
without even opening the application and
this is a range of pressure that this
the sensors can sense so in drawing
applications or signing your signature
you get a much more accurate
illustration based on that pressure if
you're watching a movie in QuickTime or
a video you can press deeper on
fast-forward and the deep you press the
faster it goes
I got that in just two takes so this is
the more the new the new trackpad a new
MacBook it's engineered like no trackpad
ever has before so let's take a look
inside because what's on the inside is
just as innovative as these features
we're looking at on the outside this is
our latest unibody architecture unibody
architecture creates the structure out
of the enclosure and you can mount
devices and components directly to that
structure like that great trackpad let's
put the logic board inside it this is
the logic board of the 11 inch MacBook
Air obviously is quite an engineering
feat to make that fit inside the new
macbook well our engineering team took
on two really huge challenges with this
the first the device with the circular
shape on the right well that's a fan
with vents support well the team
designed this new MacBook with removing
all fans and vents to make it the first
famous map for ever so it operates
silently so here's that logic board now
without the fan what our engineering
team did is remarkable that's the new
logic board inside the MacBook they've
miniaturized it it is the densest logic
board ever in a Mac it is 67% smaller
that is one-third the size of the
previous smallest logic board this is
insane it's powered by an Intel Core M
fifth generation 14 nanometer process
you can configure it with speeds up to
1.3 gigahertz which can be turbocharged
running up to 2.9 gigahertz and yet all
that performance just consumes 5 watts
it's incredibly energy efficient so now
we can fit that incredible the new logic
board right inside the new MacBook so
what do we do with the rest of that
space we fill it with batteries
this uses Apple's asymmetric battery
technology you can see the cells are
different sizes but the team went so
much further with the batter's battery
chemistry in this new MacBook
traditional cells rectangular not only
the X&Y but in the Z thickness as well
well that doesn't work very well if you
have a product this thin this contoured
if you try to fit a rectangular cell in
it you see you left with a lot of empty
space we don't want to ship air we want
to ship batteries so what the team has
done is amazing they've created the
batteries in sheets that can be
terrorists with contoured shapes that
fit the contours of the MacBooks
enclosure so now you can fit battery
technology inside it like this it's far
more efficient in fact we get 35% more
battery within the same space by these
new contoured cells and that allows us
to deliver all-day battery life in the
new MacBook
that's up to nine hours wireless web up
to 10 hours iTunes movie playback and so
much more it is an incredibly innovative
notebook on the inside as well as the
outside now how do you connect with the
world well this is our vision for the
future the notebook and the only
intelligent vision of the future of the
notebook is one without wires we don't
have to plug up cables to connect to
things that's why we have both dual
stream 802 11 AC and Bluetooth 4.0
built-in with all the great new
advancements in OS 10 Yosemite and
continuity you can connect and share
like never before wirelessly you can
connect peripherals you can connect to
printers you can share content because
this is the vision for the future of the
notebook one of extreme portability when
you want to watch content into TV you do
with airplay you want to share files you
do it with airdrop when you want to get
on a cellular network from your macbook
it can initiate a hotspot on your iPhone
when you want to kick back and listen to
music you can do it wirelessly with some
very cool beats speakers and headphones
now of course there is a time when it's
really convenient to plug in a cable
that's what you wanted want to charge
quickly so we do have a port on here for
power and the team decided if you're
going to have a port on it let's make
the most versatile connector we've ever
put in a notebook and sure enough they
did one connector supports USB data
DisplayPort power
HDMI VGA all through one connector
the technology behind this is a brand
new standard called USB see an apple
along with the number of other companies
have all worked together to create this
new industry standard and you're going
to see it appear in more products but
first you see here on the new macbook
here's the cable for USB see it's 1/3
the size of its standard USB cable it's
easier to use because it's reversible no
more trying to dive underneath and
figure out which way it goes and it's
the most versatile connector you'll see
adapters from Apple as well as many
third parties to support all these
different interfaces all through one
connector so this is the new MacBook
with its incredible keyboard with its
butterfly mechanism its new multi-touch
trackpad that's force sensitive a
perfectly matched 12 inch Retina display
with over 3.3 million pixels our most
dense logic board ever incredible new
contoured battery technology all packed
in to the thinnest lightest most
beautiful notebook we have ever made
comes in silver Space Gray and a
stunning gold yes
we're really proud of the fact this is
the most environmentally friendly
notebook we've ever made Energy Star 6.1
EPEAT gold arsenic-free display glass
mercury free BFR free PVC free the first
time in a Mac beryllium free and of
course highly recyclable and I think the
team's probably Protestant it's also the
world's most energy-efficient notebook
we really love them could it be proud of
this new MacBook and I have a brief
video to tell you more about it the new
MacBook is the result of a collective
obsession to simplify its essential
components to create the most efficient
design possible it's a product that
couldn't exist without invention across
many disciplines our full-size keyboard
is the most familiar comfortable and
accurate typing platform it defined the
width of the new MacBook to make it
thinner and more precise we created a
sturdy single assembly butterfly
mechanism combined with a new stainless
steel dome switch this reinforces the
keyboards balance and stability each
individual key is now led by a single
led this enables better more deliberate
illumination a Retina display delivers
the very best viewing experience to
engineer the thinnest Retina screen for
a Mac we've refined every component from
the glass down to the pixels
it delivers the vivid brightness and
performance you'd expect but in a design
that's thinner lighter and 30% more
power efficient we've designed a force
sensing multi-touch trackpad this adds a
new dimension of interaction touch
sensors make the entire glass surface
active force sensors measure a wide
range of pressure from the lightest tab
to the deepest press the pressure you
apply activates an electromagnet that
responds with tactile feedback so now
instead of just seeing what's happening
in the screen you feel it too
to make all-day battery life possible we
have developed new battery technologies
we actually change the construction and
internal chemistry of the cells which
are now manufactured into screen sheets
these sheets are stacked in a terraced
structure that was developed along with
the external enclosure the design allows
for 35 percent greater battery capacity
in this compact space to maximize
performance we took an extreme approach
to miniaturization components were
optimized and engineered to fit together
to create the highest density mag logic
board yet it's actually two-thirds
smaller than any with design perform a
fundamental goal was to eliminate the
need for vents fans or any moving parts
allowing it to operate in silence by
consolidating the antenna with the
bottom case we were able to design an
integrated aluminium hinge
this innovation along with its unibody
enclosure makes this the first all-metal
MacBook
this product is not only thin and light
it's advanced wireless technologies make
it truly portable when you actually need
to plug in the new USB type-c connector
is a single port for charging video
output and data transfer the result of
all of this is a product that's only
thirteen point one millimeters thick and
weighs just two pounds
to create the new MacBook we were
uncompromising in its design and
engineering we set a new standard for
portability while enhancing its
fundamental components to deliver what
we believe is the best MacBook yet
hashtag Macbook lust the new MacBook
starts with 12.1 inch Retina display a
1.1 gigahertz Intel Core M a large 8
gigs of internal memory and a large 256
gigabyte flash storage device at just
$12.99
and for those yeah and for those who
want even more and get a faster
processor and twice that internal
storage for just $15.99 it is absolutely
incredible beautiful in our most
advanced notebook ever will begin to
ship in a number of countries in just a
month April 10th and the new MacBook
joins the MacBook Air and MacBook Pro to
make this our best notebook lineup ever
now we have some updates to the others
as well
the MacBook Air is being updated to
faster 5th gen Intel Core i5 and i7
processors they have faster Thunderbolt
connectors Thunderbolt 2 and the 13-inch
configuration gets flash that's now
twice as fast as before and those will
be shipping starting today in the
13-inch MacBook Pro as an update as well
it's getting the new force touch
trackpad that we just talked about with
MacBook also in the 13-inch MacBook Pro
it's getting faster processors with
faster Core i5 and i7 processors and
it's getting twice as fast flash as well
and we've been able to get another hour
of battery life out of it now ten hours
of all-day battery life
and that's chicken today as well and
that is our news on the MacBook Tim